a question from nyada thomas was steve
young's sixth touchdown performance in
super bowl 29 the greatest individual
performance in super bowl history
well it certainly ranks right up there
mike and i remember that when he
remember when he pulled the monkey off
his shoulder and and threw it down
because he'd finally done what montana
did for the 49ers
they're all my top ones are all 49ers i
mean you look at jerry rice and super
bowl 23 the 11 catchers for 215 yards
and the touchdown and the joe montana
dan marino super bowl in 84. that was
probably the greatest quarterback
match-up that we've ever seen up until
this year but montana was outstanding in
that game 331 yards and three touchdowns
and he ran for 59 yards and another
touchdown so those would be probably my
top three from the offensive standpoint
of course von miller had the great game
a few years ago but those were
outstanding performances all three of
them
peter king mentioned the moreno and
montana match up from super bowl 19. it
ended up being very very disappointing
it was a blowout win 38-16 i think was
the final score of that super bowl the
win at stamford stadium by the 49ers
close to home but not quite home and
it's funny that i'm thinking of peter
king because
the steve young super bowl peter tells a
story about steve young throwing up red
gatorade all over all over peter's i
think shoes or something i can't
remember exactly where it happened but
it's an unpleasant story that he tells
from time to time about his experience
with steve young that night um when i
think of great individual performances i
can't help but think of tara owens from
super bowl 39 nine catches 122 yards
best player on the field that day still
had a broken bone in his leg from the
roy williams tackle in the regular
season the cowboys safety the rule would
be named for him the horse caller tackle
rule
and sheree i've been talking about
thinking about t.o a lot now because
it shows me how much our attitudes have
shifted they haven't completely evolved
but they've shifted because terrell
owens
wanted greater financial security from
the eagles after he played that heroic
super bowl he wanted more guaranteed
money from the eagles their attitude was
you've signed a contract too bad tough
crap deal with it and he became
incredibly disruptive until the point
that they kicked him out of the building
and eventually released him but uh fans
were much less forgiving to to in 2005
than i think they would be today and
that i think they will be for deshaun
watson wanting out of houston
there's no question mike and it's a
great point because i remember him doing
sit-ups in the driveway and all those
things that he was doing and he was
really uh harshly criticized and we
haven't seen that from deshaun watson
now i'm sure there are texans fans out
there who are mad at deshaun watson
right now but we're not hearing the
criticism of john watson for asking for
a trade because we're more used to these
trade scenarios perhaps than we were
back then
i think part of it too is he hasn't said
anything he hasn't done anything it's
just reports and i think that maybe if
you're an ardent texans fan you're just
hoping that if you ignore it everything
will be fine and everything will be
normal and training camp opens and
desean watson's there i have a feeling
that's not going to happen in part
because i have a feeling he's going to
be traded before that all comes to an
end but players have more rights and
greater power than they ever have and i
think that's good for sport i still
don't know why sharing the fans line up
with the billionaires
against the millionaires because if
anything you can identify with the
players not the billionaires who live in
this alternate reality
isn't that the truth mike let's side
with the millionaires instead of the
billionaires every time
you